I know you.
Alhamdulillah.
for wheelch.
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
Continuing
in
authored by
in the chapter of repentance. This is
the last narration in the chapter of
repentance. So we began with the chapter
of sincerity
followed by the chapter of repentance
and then the next chapter inshallah is
the chapter of patience. All three are
very strongly connected.
He mentions a narration on the authority
of
and keep in mind
as it is obvious.
all other scholars of hadith
and all other authors may mention a
particular narration
in a particular chapter.
this doesn't mean that the narration
only has one theme. That's not the case.
There could be a narration that has a
multitude of intertwined themes and the
narration is applicable to all of them.
However, some authors will place each
narration in its most obvious theme.
In its most obvious theme. Other authors
will place a narration
in its least obvious theme in order to
remind or redirect people's
understanding of a particular narration.
So for instance, Albkari
is
very well known for placing narrations
in chapters
that seemingly have no connection to the
chapter. They seemingly have no
connection to the chapter. You will
place an narration in a chapter and you
will that will leave the reader puzzled
positively puzzled. Why in the world
does this narration have anything to do
with this particular chapter? However,
the reason that he does this is to call
people's attention to an aspect of the
narration
that is usually overlooked due to an
overwhelming theme that overshadows it
that is found in in the particular
narration or even the verse. And the
Quran is the same way.
We have other authors Iben
and Ibuza.
They also have books that they wrote
that are part of the category because
the the term
it's a type of book.
It's not the name of the book. The name
of Bkari is not
the name of the book is
it has a very long name but that is the
category of book also Muslim
his book is referred to as
that's the name of his book altasar it's
for us it is extremely expansive
but
mean and the abridged or the summarized
book of narrations. But all of these
books belong to a category of books of
hadith known as
what is a category? It's a type of book
where the author has set for himself
parameters
of authenticity that every single
narration
he mentions in the book
will only be
at least as authentic as the parameters
that he has set. So he won't mention any
inauthentic narrations according to the
parameters he has set. Those
conditions may be extremely
stringent al- bkari very very very
high level of authenticity
and others may be a very low threshold
of authenticity like
it's considered to be a it's also
considered to be a which is another type
of book.
So these books you have
Muslim
etc. It's a it's a collection. It's a
type of collection.
You look at
very very
curious way of categorizing narrations.
Ib Kuza or and Ib Hibban specifically
Iban who was Ibusa's student went out of
his way to make his book as inaccessible
as possible.
As inaccessible as possible. Yes. To
make it extremely difficult for anyone
who picks up the book to find anything
he's looking for. He went out of his way
to make the book as inaccessible as
possible. Person may say, "Why in the
world would you do something that?"
The answer is to repel grifters.
To repel hackers, grifters, people who
would only use his book just to find
what they're looking for and put it
down. No, you want the knowledge in this
book. There's no indexes and all of the
chapters are scattered.
They're all scattered and all of the
narrations are in the least probable
place to find a narration. He looked at
the 300 years of books of hadith that
came before him. How all the scholars
categorize their books. For instance,
usually based on the pillars of Islam,
right? What is Islam? Islam is the
testimony of
Allah the establishment of prayer,
giving zakah, fasting, Ramadan al etc.
This is how alkari c organized his book.
So you would find it categorized like
that. You want the book of salah, you're
going to find it before the book of zak.
If you want the book regarding
interpretation of dreams, you'll find it
towards the end etc. They all kind of
followed in suit after
in his.
So what did I do? He did exactly the
opposite of that entirely. The whole
book is scattered
and scholars came after that dedicated
careers to organizing the book. people
who specialized in the book. But Iban
Rahim, one of the greatest scholars of
hadith and
that ever existed on this earth. He put
it in that way for a reason to where
that his book would only be quoted by
those who are most proficient in the
science of hadith. Most
who work the hardest in order to
achieve his
his contribution to the science of
hadith which is not a small
contribution. It is a huge contribution
and
is not a book that can be done without.
And so all of this is why in order to
explain the narration or bring different
aspects to the narration to a person's
attention
does something similar but his book is
named
is the guardians of the righteous. the
righteous, the general people. It's not
made for strictly scholars. It's not
made for strictly students of hadith or
what have you. And so he set out to make
his book as accessible as possible.
However, the chapters are set up in a
way that
call attention of the reader to the most
prominent aspects of the narration.
But it doesn't mean that that is the
only theme of the narration. It's
important to look past that theme in
order to see other aspects of the
narration. And there are examples of
this in the Quran. Many examples. I'll
mention one and then we will complete
the hadith tomorrow inshallah. For
instance, in the Quran,
we have Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions the story of the bakar
the cow of beni is
that they were commanded by Musam to
slaughter.
Now Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala begins
with the story of the cow.
And
recall when MS told his people, Allah
has commanded you to slaughter a cow.
They start to question him. Poor
etiquette, poor belief and a lack of
drive to fulfill what their prophet
commands them. So they start to
question, what kind of cow is it? How
old is it? What does it do? What color
is it? etc etc.
Then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
after that
and recall when you
when when a murder took place. So what
is a greater crime?
Murder or asking too too many questions?
Obviously murder. Murder is a more
severe crime. And that murder
took place before
the issue of the cow. But Allah mentions
in chronic chronological order. He
mentions it out of order. He mentions
the cow and the questioning first. Then
he mentions he tail ends that with the
murder. Why? Because naturally if a
person hears at the beginning of the
story that a murder took place, their
mind is set there. They are going to
overlook the crime,
the crime of questioning their prophet.
And so it will seem as though those
questions are just part for the course.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
the questioning and the cow first. And
so we think that that is the main topic
of the story. Then we find out that this
was all because of a murder that took
place.
The reason that this is put out of order
in that way is in order that the murder
and its heinousness does not overshadow
the heinousness of
questioning their prophets and
messengers and being slow to implement.
This
methodology of putting things in
order is found throughout the Quran and
the scholars of Islam have taken from
this from different angles. Some of them
take the easy
the the path that makes their books more
accessible. Others take the path that
makes their books most inaccessible etc.
in order to develop their reader
in the way that they are attempting
to develop each based on his
particular goals that he set out to
accomplish by authoring his books.
May Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
have mercy upon our scholars. May he
subhanahu wa'ta'ala raise their levels.
May he subhanahu wa ta'ala lift their
remembrance and increase their
reward.
and a Muhammad while early he was heavy.